i want to in particular recognize
secretary marcus
the time that we spent with the
dedicated men and women of
cbp
really has reinforced the work that
secretary mayarkas has done we're not
exactly where we want to be yet but we
have seen extreme progress over these
last few months because of his
dedication and his efforts
my how time flies that was the vice
president one year ago on her first and
only trip to the southern border since
then the migrant crisis has continued to
spiral customs and border protection
reporting another record number of
encounters last month and our borders
are still nowhere to be found at the
border let's bring in former utah
congressman jason chaffetz he is also a
fox news contributor jason always great
to see you i want to put these numbers
up on the screen because it's important
this is in may those who were granted
parole you see 51
132 that's up 28
since april the associated press had
this headline quoting here paroled
migrants say they were not screened for
asylum or even asked why they came to
the u.s they receive a stapled packet
with a blue stamp that stays when parole
expires and when it expires jason off
they go
yeah nothing happens trace i mean
they're not checked for covet nothing
that's going along here it is absolutely
stunning that the president of the
united states since he started working
in the senate in the 1970s has never
been to our our southern border and
kamala harris that clip you showed is
about a year old
you have secretary marcus saying that he
has operational control of the border
yet the numbers are absolutely record
highs we've never seen numbers this high
of people coming across the border since
they started counting people coming
across the borders so there is no
control no desire they offer a magnet
and they're they literally are streaming
across the border by the hundreds of
thousands you talk about the record
number of migrants encountered in may
let's put that on the screen 239 000
plus that again is a record and you know
the truth is nobody knows the exact
number because you figure in jason the
gotaways and the others but you have
analysts and you have the border agents
that we talk to and they say you know
the number is very close to since joe
biden took office two million migrants
entering this country that's bigger than
a lot of states populations
yeah that 239 thousand is one month and
these poor border patrol agents the ice
officers the people that have to deal
with this
we we treat these people coming across
the border better than we do americans
they're given all sorts of benefits they
give free reign they can come and they
can work in the united states of america
and don't tell me that that doesn't also
contribute to the crunch on housing and
food and inflation because they need a
place to sleep at a place to eat and
they want to get jobs and everything
else and so
it's just absolutely untenable and what
the administration is saying about it
what they're doing about is nothing they
are literally doing nothing trace to
secure that border that's not jason
chaffetz saying that that's the border
patrol the consequences i mean what you
go you know come back to the vice
president kamala harris she hasn't been
down there in a year and apparently
nobody has said anything about it
where's the pressure
uh there isn't i mean you hear some
republican lawmakers uh talking about
this you hear the people in texas and
these border states talking about this
but i hope people understand and realize
the devastation the human toll the drug
trafficking the human trafficking the
number of women that are raped they are
complicit in human trafficking and yet
there is no outrage in this country uh
in mass about this this mass might it's
not just a migration they're wrapping
people and they're pulling people and
they're they're encouraging and being
about 20 seconds left here and i want to
get this in because when the vice
president when when president biden was
vice president the new york post says
that hunter biden met with four
oligarchs closely allied with vladimir
putin and others say look there's only
one reason you meet and that's influence
your final thoughts jason
not only do you do have that going on in
russia but he's meeting with chinese
intelligence officers romanian thugs
that have been convicted uh people in
mexico it's a worldwide phenomenon the
biden crime family connections are
absolutely stunning and still get
continued to be exposed to this day yeah
jason great to have you on thank you sir
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight